-All right, this year,
I'm sticking
to my New Year's resolutions.
I am saying yes to everything.
[ Knocking ]
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey, Sarah.
-Do you think
I could get a raise?
-Yes.
-Yes!
-Hey, Jimbo,
you coming to my one-man show?
It's Saturday at 8:00.
-Yes.
-8:00 a.m.
[ Laughter ]
[ Knocks ]
-Yo, Jimmy, The Roots and I
have decided we're gonna be
a kazoo band now.
[ Kazoos play ]
That's not gonna be a problem,
is it?
-Yes.
-Yes, it's going to be
a problem,
or, yes, it's not
gonna be a problem?
-Yes?
-Ha!
You heard him, boys.
Polish those kazoos.
We got a show to do!
[ Kazoos playing ]
-I did it.
I said yes to everything.
It wasn't that bad.
[ Cellphone vibrating ]
"Potential spam."
Hello?
-Hi. Do you have a moment
to talk about
your car's extended warranty?
[ Laughter ]
-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y-Y--
Nooooo!